PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome back to 6849.
You may recall or have heard
that this film crew from Japan
is here.
They're from a program
called [? Gachan, ?]
which is about showing
all the cool things
that happen in universities
around the world
to students in Japan.
So don't mind them,
but you're going
to have to sign a
release form at the end.
I apparently don't need
you to sign a release form.
It just works.
We're talking about
origami today.
We began a series of lectures
on computational origami.
We're going to do some
design, some actual folding,
and some foldability
algorithm stuff.
Does everyone have one of these
strips and a square of paper?
You don't.
Who has the master?
Why don't you grab a few?
Some of these.
Here's the package.
Lots of stuff.
The paper comes from
the [? Gachan ?] team,
so thanks to them.
This is stuff you use in
your adding machine, I guess.
That's where it comes from.
Yes.
You need one of each.
Go for it.
Open it.
Let's get started.
Where is my chalk?
So just to warm you up,
I want to do some folding
and give you some terminology.
I know some of you have
done origami before,
but a lot of you
haven't, so bear with me.
I will try to do this quickly.
And even for those
who have done origami,
you may not have done
origami math before.
That's why you're here.
So things like a
piece of paper, which
you might take for
granted, I'm going
to define here to
be a 2D polygon.
There's actually many
interesting definitions
of a piece of paper,
but for today at least,
most of the time, we'll
think about polygon.
Usually, you think of a
square piece of paper,
but "polygon" would be the
geometer's generalization
of that.
Also, the polygon has
distinguished sides.
So distinguished
top and bottom side.
In practice, with standard
kami paper from Japan,
you have the colored
side and the white side,
so that's one clear distinction.
Maybe we call the
colored side the top.
Doesn't really matter, just
so we can tell things apart,
and in particular tell
mountains from valleys.
That's our motivation.
So a crease in a piece
of paper, this I'm
going to think abstractly as
just a line segment or some one
dimensional curve drawn
on the piece of paper.
And then we have crease pattern.
This is just a bunch of creases,
so a bunch of line segments
drawn on the piece of paper.
If you are graph
theoretically inclined,
I would think of
this as a planar
graph drawn on the paper.
If you're not graph
theoretically inclined,
just ignore that definition.
They're the same thing.
That's a crease pattern.
So for example, the thing
we're going to be folding
is this very simple
pinwheel, and this
is an example of a
crease pattern that
folds into that pinwheel.
So here, the lines
are distinguished.
There's two different kinds, the
red lines and the blue lines,
but ignore that for now.
That's a bunch of
creases which you
could put in and
make that thing.
Before we get there, I want
the notion of a folded state.
So this is all pretty normal
if you're an origamist.
This is really something
only the mathematicians use,
this term, folded state.
Formally, this is what we refer
to as the finished product.
This pinwheel is a folded
state of this piece of paper.
Clear?
Defining that is a real pain,
and you can look at chapter 11,
I think, in the textbook.
Maybe I'll talk about
it at some point,
but I don't want
to get distracted
by how you define what
a folded state is.
But you're not
allowed to stretch,
you're not allowed to tear.
It should be a
nice, valid folding.
You can't cross yourself.
So that's this notion
of folded state.
And if you take a folded
state and then unfold it--
this is something you can
do with a folded state--
you get a crease pattern.
So I can take this
pinwheel, unfold it,
and I can see which
lines are creased
to make that pinwheel happen.
So that's the crease
pattern of a folded state.
Today especially, and
a lot of the field
is concerned with the idea
of flat foldings, which
are a particular kind of folded
state that lives in the plane,
lying in the plane.
Of course, it doesn't
literally lie on the plane.
There's lots of layers
stacked on top of each other,
but geometrically,
everything has
been collapsed onto one
slightly thickened plane here.
So this is a flat origami.
This is also a flat
origami, the trivial kind.
That's a flat folding.
And when this is possible,
we call that crease pattern
flat foldable.
And finally, we get to the
idea of mountains and valleys.
So a mountain crease is
when the bottom sides
touch, and a valley crease
is when the top sides touch.
So remember my
distinguished sides.
I'll call the
colored side the top,
so then this is a
mountain crease over here
because I'm bringing the
two white sides together,
and where's a valley?
I guess this is a valley, where
I'm bringing the two colored
sides, the two top
sides, together.
Together, that
makes this pattern,
and hopefully, that
matches up with here.
I mean, it's symmetric.
You could flip everything over.
You'd just get the
inverted color pattern.
It doesn't really matter which
side you defined to be which,
but the point is to
distinguish which
are mountains versus
which are valleys.
You get different
parity, it looks
like, I have matched up there.
So let's fold this, just
for some experience,
if you've never made one before.
Take your square piece of
paper, and to get started,
let's say with
the white side up,
just fold along
the two diagonals,
the valley folds, bringing
the two white sides together.
So you fold along one
diagonal, then you unfold, then
you fold along the
other diagonal.
How are we doing?
Couple diagonals.
I have the big sheet.
I should be going slower.
So now, I want to fold
that inner square,
and we've conveniently
marked the center point.
So I'm going to fold each of
the four edges of the square
to the center, and
make sure to line up
the left and right edges,
and that guarantees that I
fold parallel to
that bottom edge.
In this case, I
just want to crease
the middle half of that line.
So I'm not creasing all the way.
I'm just creasing
in the middle half
here to make that one
edge of the square,
and then I turn and I
repeat that four times.
Switch sides for
different visibility.
This is not the usual
way to teach this model,
but I think it's the
mathematically appropriate way.
I'm trying to make that crease
pattern as quickly as I can.
I did it with the white
side up because I'm
folding everything
valley, which is easier.
In reality, I want
these to be mountains.
When I turn them over, they're
all mountains, and I'm happy.
We made some extra creases
here, which we didn't need to.
How are we doing?
How many people are
done with those?
How many people are not?
Couple people.
Sarah, hurry up.
Now comes the fun
part, and this is
to give you an idea of what
general origami folds can
be like.
I want to simultaneously
fold all those creases
that I put in except
for the center, where
it's supposed to be uncreased.
So I'm going to bring those
four edges of the square in,
and if you do it
right, you'll end up
with these four flaps
sticking out of the top.
It's not going to lie flat.
We don't have enough
creases in yet.
But we have these four
flaps of the pinwheel,
and then you just
get to choose, do I
flip them over one
way or the other?
If you flip them over as much
as they go in that direction--
I'll try to match the figure.
I'll put this guy
over at the left,
crease him in, put this guy
down at that end, and this guy
over to the right,
and this guy up.
I get my pinwheel.
If that doesn't work out
for you, you can try again.
It's not so hard, but
it gives you some idea
that putting all these
creases in at once
is kind of necessary
for this to happen.
In particular, if you
look at the crease pattern
of this model, there
is no fold that
goes all the way
through the square,
so you can't make a
first fold and then
make a second fold and so on.
You really have to
do this all at once.
There's many ways to do it, some
of which are more intuitive,
but I thought this simultaneous
collapse is the coolest.
It's nice and fourfold
symmetric as you do it, I guess,
if you do it right.
I think this even folds rigidly.
That's to give you
some intuition,
some real, practical
origami experience.
And you get an idea of
what a crease pattern is,
when a mountain valley is.
I have two more
terms and then we
can go to math, some real stuff.
There's two notions that
involve mountains and valleys.
One is a mountain-valley
assignment,
and this is something
that goes together
with the crease pattern.
And this specifies which
creases are mountains
and which are valleys.
Did you all get it?
Good.
The pinwheel, I mean.
So you could think of this
as a coloring of the edges,
whatever.
In this case, I'm
simultaneously using color red
to denote mountains and
blue to denote valleys,
and also, the standard
in origami world,
although it's a bit
annoying, is dot dash
means mountain and
dash means valley.
That's pretty common.
You'll see that throughout.
That was invented in the
1950s, I guess, by Yoshizawa,
maybe earlier.
Somewhere around there.
And then if I take a
crease pattern together
with a mountain-valley
assignment,
I'm going to call this a
mountain-valley pattern.
That's the picture that
I'm really drawing here.
Sometimes it's useful to think
of these as coming together,
sometimes as separate.
You're going to see this
terminology all over the place,
so I figure I should define it.
And sometimes, m is
mountain, v is valley.
Now we can do some fun stuff.
I showed you this
pinwheel to give you
an idea of more
complicated folds,
the general origami folds.
But today, I want to focus
on relatively simple kind
of folds, which is
called simple folds.
Unlike this thing where I have
to simultaneously collapse
many creases, a simple fold
just involves one crease.
It is a fold along
a single line,
and we fold it by plus
or minus 180 degrees.
So depending which
way you're counting,
plus 180 is maybe valley,
minus 180 is mountain.
If I start with a flat folding,
after I make a simple fold,
I will again have
a flat folding.
What we're interested
in is, what
can you make by a
sequence of simple folds?
I start from a
square paper, say,
and I make a sequence
of simple folds.
At all times, I will
be flat folding.
It's easy to get there.
The pinwheel is something you
could not make in this model.
It's a restricted
model, but it's still
surprisingly powerful.
You still get a
universality result.
Even with simple folds, you
can make any flat thing.
And if you relax this
constraint and don't
say it's plus or
minus 180, then you
can actually make any
3D thing you want.
So that's the first thing
we will prove today,
and that's in the
origami design world.
And then we'll go to
origami foldability.
I'll give you a crease pattern.
I want to know, can it be folded
by a sequence of simple folds?
That's a much harder problem,
but some cases are easy.
So this the universality result
I mentioned in lecture one.
This is going to be the
inefficient version,
but we're going to
prove that everything
can be folded from
a square paper.
I'm going to be more
precise about what
I mean by everything.
So I'm going to imagine there
are a bunch of polygons in 3D
and they're somehow
joined together
into one connected mass.
This could be a
polyhedron like a cube,
it could be a
polyhedron like a bunny,
it could be some
crazy, thorny mess,
but each piece
locally is a polygon,
and you just stick a
whole bunch of them
together to some
connected thing.
Plus you get to specify what
color, what side of the paper
you want to be visible on
each of those polygons.
You can even do that on
each side of the polygon
if you want.
And you can fold that thing from
a big enough piece of paper,
such as a big enough square, a
big enough rectangle, whatever
you feel like.
Bicolor paper here
refers to the idea
that your paper is
different colors
on one side and the other,
so white on one side,
colored on the other
side, white on one side,
black on the other
side, whatever.
We usually try to draw that
with the folded over corner.
There we go, bicolor paper.
So for example,
for fun, here's how
you could imagine this
design by John Montroll.
This is folded from a square
of paper, white on one side,
black on the other.
It's a zebra.
And you could imagine
the input to that
problem was a bunch of polygons.
There's some white polygons,
some black polygons.
Together, they form
a connected union,
and that could be the input.
This could be an output to
how you fold your square
to make that color pattern.
Of course, if you gave this
input to that algorithm,
you'll get a much uglier
folding than the one designed
by a human, but that's the idea.
You could also
imagine you're just
given a polygon
you want to make.
You say, I want to make
a horse, a flat horse.
Then you could give
that to this algorithm
and it will tell you
how to fold a horse.
That's the general idea.
So how do we prove that?
Want to make everything.
So this is an early result in
computational origami design,
I think from 1998, probably.
Trial version here is in 2000.
Any ideas how to prove this?
How can we make anything?
Got to get you
thinking a little bit.
We have a subtle hint.
So the idea is to take
a really long strip,
much longer than this
one, and fold it, and just
wrap around your polyhedron
over and over and over,
and eventually make
whatever you want.
So it's going to
be a little flimsy,
but mathematically,
it'll work perfectly.
So first thing to do is
fold your paper, whatever
shape it is, down to a
long, narrow strip, so
a long, narrow rectangle.
Conveniently, you have your
strips of paper already,
but if you started
with a square,
the first thing you'd
do is accordion pleat it
down to just one
edge of the square.
Crazy already.
If you started with a
square, this is a bad idea.
If you started with a strip,
it's actually pretty good.
It's probably close to optimal.
But now, how do I actually, say,
wrap everything with the strip?
Let's be more formal about that.
The first thing I'm
going to do, which
is a common trick in
computational geometry,
it's like, well,
polygons are confusing.
I like triangles better.
They're much simpler.
So just triangulate
all the polygons.
If I have some crazy
polygon, imagine
that's some piece
of the zebra, I'll
just subdivide it
into triangles.
There's standard
algorithms to do this.
I don't want to go into that.
You can just add a bunch of
these diagonals to the polygon,
just keep adding them as long
as they don't cross each other.
When you're done, it
will be triangulated.
You can do that efficiently,
linear time, even.
That's a little bit
easier to think about.
Now I just have to figure
out how to wrap one triangle
and then how to combine those
wrappings together somehow.
Then I could go through
triangle by triangle,
visit everything, cover
everything I need to cover.
So that's what
we're going to do.
Cover each of these
triangles in some order.
We're going to cover
each one at least once,
possibly more if
we're not careful.
For starters, we'll
be not careful.
And we're going to do this
by using a zigzag path
parallel to the
next edge starting
from the opposite corner.
So some technical details.
Much easier to see in a picture,
so let me draw you a picture.
Let's say we want to
visit this triangle first,
and after we visit
this triangle,
let's say we've
planned out that we're
going to visit
this triangle next.
After that one, we're going
to go to this triangle.
So this is what I'd call
the next edge, because it's
the edge connecting
to the next triangle.
So I'd like to zigzag
parallel to this edge,
so I want to go back
and forth like that.
And then it says I want to start
at the opposite corner, which
is this one.
So I'm going to
start here, and I'll
draw this a little
more precisely.
I'm going to take
my strip and just
go this way for a little while,
and turn around and come back
this way, and then
turn around, and we're
going to see how to do
turning around in a moment, so
something like that.
Now I've got to start planning
a little bit, because I want
to do this triangle in the same
way, meaning I want to go back
and forth parallel
to the next edge
starting at the opposite corner.
So that means next thing I want
to do is start at this corner,
so I need to set this up
so that I don't end here.
I'd like to end here.
You can do that just by
doing one more iteration.
If I end up with the
wrong parity-- here
it looks like I won't too much.
Here it's a little ugly.
Got a little bit of uncovered
portion of the triangle,
so you need a slightly
different turn here.
Then I'll just come and
sort of overlap myself.
That's OK.
I just have to cover
it at least once.
And then I do some
kind of turn here,
and then I'm going to do this.
So there's obviously
some questions here.
How do I make these
180 degree turns?
How do I make an arbitrary turn?
How do I turn even when I'm
allowed to overlap myself?
I'm not going to worry
about that too much,
basically the same.
Basically, how do I turn?
How do I turn?
Well, let's take our
strips and do some turning,
and I have a slide
to follow along.
I have a big strip,
a little bit too big.
So the idea is you
have your strip,
you're gone merrily along,
and at some point you decide,
oh, I really need to
make a 132 degree turn.
I mean, it could be
anything because here, we've
got to make some crazy turn.
We don't know what
the amount is.
So the turn gadget
is always the same.
You start out by making a
mountain fold perpendicular
to the strip.
So just fold in
half, so to speak.
Of course, half of
this is connected
to everything you built already.
The other half, you don't know.
And then you take the back layer
and fold it to whatever angle
you want.
You have this degree of freedom
wherever you want to put it.
So for example, if we wanted
to make an obtuse angle.
I'm always going to fold
incident to that bottom corner.
It's a little hard to
handle, but you get the idea.
That's a nice, perfect
turn right there.
Looks even cooler on my side.
You just see the angular
bisector or something.
So that's a decent obtuse angle.
Things are little bit uglier
when you make an acute angle,
something like this.
You could make whatever
angle you want.
You should have
enough strip to make
several turns if
you feel like it.
If I make an acute angle like
this, I get some overhang.
So I have what I want, which
is the strip coming here
and the strip coming
here at the extremes,
but over in this corner I
have some extra material,
and it could be a lot.
But whatever it is,
I'll just rid of it
by folding it
underneath repeatedly.
In this case, one
fold, it's gone.
In general, when
I make that fold,
it might come out over here and
I have to wrap around that cone
several times.
There's probably an
example of that here.
This figure in the
middle version,
you start just the same by
folding a super acute angle.
I fold that corner over and
it overhangs a little bit
on the bottom,
but it got tinier.
And if you just wrap
it around the corner,
eventually it will disappear and
you have exactly what you want,
which is a strip coming
horizontally and then a strip
coming off diagonally at
whatever angle you wanted.
So that's really easy.
That's what we
call a turn gadget.
So we do this
using turn gadgets.
Now, you can't actually turn
with 180 degree angle here,
which is why in
this picture, what I
drew was a 90 degree turn and
then another 90 degree turn.
You can do that
however you want.
That's one way.
In fact, the way I've shown
it, it would be orthogonal,
but doesn't really matter.
These turns are not much harder.
You just do one or two of
those turns to get aligned.
And you can decide here, do
I turn around to the left
or do I turn around to the
right, and then I zigzag?
Depending on which way I
go, I will end up either
at this corner or this corner,
and if my next triangle's
up here, then I want to
end up at this corner.
If my next triangle's
over here, then I
want to end up at this corner.
You plan out ahead of
time what order you're
going to visit the
triangles, just decide.
Technically, it's like the
traveling salesman problem,
but you don't have to be
efficient at the moment.
We're not worrying
about efficiency.
Just visit triangle after
triangle, keep going to one
you haven't visited before.
It could be far away from you.
Maybe you have to go over
many triangles you visited
before, but eventually
you'll get to one
you haven't visited until
you're done, and then boom,
you've made anything.
Amazing.
We haven't quite
proved the theorem.
At this point, we can make any
connected union of polygons.
This is one polygon,
but if you're
in 3D, when you cross over
from one polygon to the next,
you might have to bend it at
some angle that's not flat,
but then you can make
any 3D thing, too.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you wrap around
the triangle whose edge type
is the bottom, how
do you do that when
the top left triangle is there?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
When I wrap around here?
AUDIENCE: No, the triangle
whose edge is the bottom edge.
PROFESSOR: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How do you do that,
given that there's
the triangle in the top left?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
The question is,
what do I do here
because I'm going to overlap
into this triangle again?
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you have to be a
little bit careful here,
and there's one other gadget
I need to mention here,
which is the hide gadget,
I think it's called.
Because I didn't fold
exactly this triangle,
I folded too much.
At this point when I have the
strip here, and maybe a little
bit out of the way,
I'd like to get rid
of all this messy stuff,
just tuck it underneath.
So I'm going to fold along this
line, fold all this stuff back
behind, and that might still be
a mess because it could stick
out over here or somewhere else.
So let me tell you about the
hide gadget a little bit,
maybe over here.
You have to be a little careful
when you do that exactly,
but it's not that hard.
So in general,
the hide gadget is
you have some convex polygon.
Here, it's always going to
be a triangle, actually,
but this would work
for any convex polygon.
You have some folding which
contains that polygon,
but it might go outside
all over the place.
That's our situation.
We want this triangle.
We have a folding that
includes the triangle
but it has all this
junk on the outside.
All you need to do is
repeatedly fold along
the extension of
each of these edges,
and you can prove-- I'm
not going to do it here
because it's a
little bit messy--
but as you fold that
thing, obviously
the area that you go
outside gets smaller,
and you do make steady
progress and eventually,
after finitely many folds,
you will have reduced
this thing down to
the convex polygon.
Just keep folding mountain
fold along each of those edges.
And I think there's even
a pseudo polynomial bound
on the number of folds
you need to make,
although I won't
go into that here.
So that's what you do
with this triangle.
Then you fold the next one, and
then you apply the hide gadget
to that triangle.
When you do that, there is
this triangle in the way.
Technically, I guess,
that wouldn't quite
be simple folds because you're
folding along this line.
You need to tuck it
in between the layers.
You have to avoid collision
with this triangle
and go underneath this one.
Hm.
I hadn't thought about that.
I'd like to say this
works with simple folds.
It sort of does in that
each fold you make,
you're just folding
along one line at a time,
but you do actually
collide in the middle.
It's not so ideal.
Origami folds, this
definitely works.
I wonder if there's a way to
do it with simple folds now.
Interesting.
Hm.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Can you
undo the corner gadget
to separate the
triangles, hide the folds,
and then put them back?
PROFESSOR: The question is,
can I pull them apart, do them
separately, and push
them back together?
Pulling them apart and pushing
them back together would not
be simple folds, I think.
Maybe you could do it.
AUDIENCE: You just
type a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
Interesting.
We should think about that.
I'm surprised this is not
known, but I'm pretty sure
now that it's not known.
Maybe first open
problem session,
we can solve that
in a few minutes.
Should be doable.
There's one more
gadget we need if we
want to get the
two color pattern.
This polygon maybe
is all one color.
Maybe it's all the
colored side of the paper.
But then at some point,
we might transition over
to another polygon, and
maybe that's the other color.
So all we're going to do
is we're, again, visiting
these triangles in some order.
Whenever we go between a black
triangle and a white triangle,
we are going to apply
a color reversal
gadget, which is very simple.
I forgot to color one
side of the strip,
so bear with me for a second,
and feel free to color
in your own strip.
Probably killing this
microphone right here.
Purple on one side,
white on the other,
although it's so transparent,
it looks almost the same.
The idea is very simple.
Where are we starting from?
We're starting from
the not purple side.
Then we make a mountain fold.
It's just like a turn gadget.
In fact, it's just like
you're turning 90 degrees.
We fold up like this, and
then we just immediately make
another 90 degree turn
without the first fold,
and we get a sharp transition
straight along the strip
from light purple to dark
purple, it looks like,
but from the white side
to the purple side.
Right when you transition
between any pair of triangles
of the opposite color, you
just apply this gadget.
You make three more
folds, and boom,
you've got your color reversal.
AUDIENCE: Can you do that again?
PROFESSOR: Do it again?
All right.
So first I make a mountain fold.
Now both sides are white.
Then I fold this guy up, so
now I have a regular 90 degree
turn, and then I
fold this guy back.
That's the tricky part because
you can't see what's happening.
Let me flip it over for you.
So I'm just folding
the top two layers here
along that 45 degree angle,
and then I get that transition.
On this side, it's
still purple and white
but it's a little uglier.
It's on the slide.
You can try again.
It doesn't say here, but
fold just the back layers.
All right?
Questions?
So that's how you can
visit all these polygons,
do color transitions, you can do
it in 3D, make any polyhedron.
A little crazy, but
the point is you
do need to do some algorithmic
construction to really see
this method work.
You need those three gadgets.
You need to be sure
that you can actually
combine them in the right way.
And I'm hand waving a little
bit some of these details.
You should be more
careful, but it works.
It's obviously
horribly inefficient,
but we can make it at least
a little bit more efficient.
Let me tell you about that.
So we can achieve something I
call pseudo efficiency, which
is if you are allowed to
start with any rectangle
you want, so in
particular, if we
start with a long strip of
paper like you did here,
then you can make
this super efficient.
The area of the piece of
paper that we start with
can be equal to the
surface area of the thing
that we want to fold.
If we could achieve this,
we would be really happy.
That means we have zero wastage.
I can't get zero
wastage, but I can
get just a little
tiny bit of wastage.
So we write epsilon for a very
tiny result, very tiny error.
So epsilon does
have to be positive,
we have to have
some wastage, but it
can be arbitrarily small.
Basically, the narrower and
longer you make your strip,
the closer the area
of your piece of paper
gets to the surface area of your
target shape, which is the best
you can hope for.
So with this crazy proviso,
which is completely impractical
we get a super
practical outcome.
And the summation is
not very practical,
but it's kind of nifty,
and I particularly
like the proof technique.
It uses a very powerful tool in
computational geometry, so let
me show it to you.
So the central issue is that
while visiting a triangle,
we actually do
pretty efficiently.
Except for the very
last strip, where
we might overlap ourselves,
except for these little corner
turn gadgets, and also
the material that's
used up in the
gadgets themselves,
We're actually really efficient.
We're covering this
triangle almost one for one.
There's a little bit
of garbage at the edge
and a little bit of
garbage at this edge,
but you could imagine as
the strip gets smaller,
this wastage gets smaller,
because it's essentially
this length times the
width of the strip up
to constant factors.
So as the strip gets narrower,
it gets closer and closer
to this thing times
0, so this wastage
gets closer and closer to 0.
Same thing over here,
same thing over here.
The real problem
at this point is
that we visit some triangles
possibly many times.
I was totally free about
how I visited triangles.
Maybe I go here and then over
here and then back over here.
I may be very wasteful.
So I just want to
avoid that wastage.
Just visit each triangle
once, exactly once.
How could you do
it exactly once?
With a great idea called
Hamiltonian refinement.
I've used this idea many times.
This was the first
time I used it.
It's very cool.
I think it goes back
to '97 or something.
So you have some triangulation.
I'm going to keep it
relatively simple.
And I'd really like to visit
each triangle exactly once.
So you think, OK,
maybe I'll start
here, then I'll go over here,
and over here, and uh oh.
Then I'm stuck.
I can't get to the
other triangles
without revisiting
an existing triangle.
It's impossible to find what
we call a Hamiltonian path.
Hamiltonian path will visit
each triangle exactly once.
But who cares about
these triangles?
I just made these
triangles to make it easier
to think about a polygon.
I could actually
cut these triangles
into smaller triangles and
ideally make it Hamiltonian.
So here's the idea.
There's this idea called the
dual graph, which is also
pretty central in
computational geometry,
where I'm going to make a
little dot for every triangle
inside each triangle,
and then I'm
going to connect
those dots whenever
there is two triangles
that share an edge.
This is called the dual graph.
These parts are called the dual
graph of the triangulation.
And in this picture,
I've got a nice, kind
of tree-shaped graph.
In general, you might
get cycles, but then
just throw away edges
until you get a tree.
I really like to
think of it as a tree,
and if I throw in enough
edges, it will be a tree.
Then my idea is I'd really
like to just visit everything
in this order, walking
around the tree.
I can go around in
a cycle and visit
each of these little
polygons exactly once.
Now, these polygons
aren't triangles,
which is kind of annoying,
so I just triangulate.
So you could just triangulate
like this, I guess.
If you want to be
excessive and simpler,
from every one of
these dots, you
can cut to the midpoint
of the three edges
and also cut to the vertices.
For every triangle, I just
cut to the three vertices
and cut to the midpoints.
You do that, and
you are guaranteed.
This gets a little messy,
but this is theoretical.
You will increase the number of
triangles by a factor of six.
Each triangle gets replaced by
six little smaller triangles.
It covers the same region,
and yet now it's Hamiltonian.
Now I can visit these triangles
and visit each triangle exactly
once, and that's how you
get pseudo efficiency.
Pretty easy once
you know this trick.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Why is it
called pseudo efficiency?
PROFESSOR: Well, I made that up.
Why is it called
pseudo efficiency?
Because it's not
really efficient.
It is efficient,
I agree, but only
with this crazy
assumption that you're
allowed to start with an
arbitrarily narrow strip,
and that's not really practical.
The practical origami problem
is I start with a square.
How big of a square do I
need to fold this shape?
And that's something we'll
talk about probably next week.
That's been studied
but it's a lot harder,
so I'm starting
with the easy stuff.
AUDIENCE: Does this necessarily
keep the mountains and valleys
that you defined
at the beginning?
PROFESSOR: Will this keep the
mountains and valleys the same?
The input didn't specify where
the mountains valleys should
be.
It just said you have
to make these polygons.
Every fold you make in this
construction will stay,
but you may make more folds that
go on top of existing folds.
I think all the mountains and
valleys that you define here
will remain mountains or valleys
as we specified, but keep
adding creases until you finish.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you
just doing a 2D case
of what we call the
3D pyramid there?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is, what about 3D?
This dual graph idea
does work in 3D.
I drew a 2D picture because
it's a lot easier to draw,
but you could imagine, for
example, you have a cube.
I'm not going to be
able to draw everything,
but you can still
form a dual graph.
I should have
triangulated the cube,
but in fact, you can do
this for any kind of graph.
I'm making a dot for
every face of the thing
that I want to make.
Each of these
polygons, I make a dot.
So in fact, if I
finished this picture,
I would get the dual
graph is the octahedron.
It would look something
like this topologically.
It doesn't have to
be a geometric thing.
It works just as well in 3D.
It actually still
works even if you just
say, for every
triangle, just cut
to the midpoints of the three
edges and to the vertices.
Then that thing
will be Hamiltonian
and you can walk around
it by doing this dual
and spanning tree construction.
I won't go into it
exactly, but that
could be done in linear time.
I'm still only making a
two dimensional surface.
I'm not trying to
make a 3D solid here,
so that's why locally,
it's two dimensional.
Locally, this just works.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: So it seems that if
you could also just stick with
the original construction,
and when you cannot find
the Hamiltonian path around
the triangles, [INAUDIBLE],
you don't cover them again, you
just get a narrow strip that
runs through them and
just rigidly [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's a neat idea.
So instead of doing this
Hamiltonian refinement,
you could visit the
triangles in any order,
but then to get
from one triangle
to some distant
triangle, instead
of covering all the triangles in
the middle which you've already
covered, which is
excessive, just go
as straight there as possible.
Locally, you'd think of that
as being a one dimensional
wastage instead of a
two dimensional wastage.
So probably you can get the
same result by that technique.
I hadn't thought of that before.
We should check it, but
I think that should work.
This is kind of cooler, just
because it uses a fancy tool,
but I imagine with a
little more analysis,
you could prove that
that works because you
know there aren't
too many triangles.
Good.
I think I'm going to
skip seem placement
and move on to foldability.
This was a little intro
to origami design.
Obviously not practical
yet, but it's something.
It's nice and universal.
You can make everything.
So let me tell you a little
bit about the other side
of the world, which is,
instead of a target shape,
what if I gave you
a crease pattern?
We just want to know, does
this crease pattern fold?
I give you the crease
pattern of that pinwheel.
I say, does this
fold into anything?
Does it fold into
a flat origami?
something else?
Can you fold it
with simple folds?
with origami folds?
Those are all
interesting questions.
We're going to start with a
very simple form of it, which
is when the piece of paper
is one dimensional, which
is almost what you
were thinking of here.
It's like strip folding, but
I'm going to furthermore require
that all the folds I make are
perpendicular to the strip
direction.
So I'm always going to fold
like this and then like this.
So it's going to remain a strip.
It'll just be a smaller strip.
I know it seems kind
of boring, but it's
something we
understand really well,
so that's why I'm going
to tell you about it.
And then it relates
to locally what
happens at one vertex
of the crease pattern,
but we'll get to
that next class.
So one dimensional flat folding.
I don't have them
anymore here, but I'm
going to redefine "piece of
paper" and all these things
because I want to
be even simpler.
So piece of paper now is going
to be a one dimensional line
segment.
A crease is going to be
a point on that segment.
In general, a crease is
one dimension smaller
than the piece of paper
you're working with.
You could actually
define "piece of paper"
to be a five dimensional
solid if you wanted.
Then creases would be
four dimensional flats,
they're called.
It's not a hyperplane.
Four dimensional flat.
That's what they're called.
Or if you wanted to do curved
creases in five dimensions,
then it's a four dimensional
surface somewhere in there.
We won't do 5D
origami in this class.
Flat folding now means that
your folding lies on a line.
Of course, it will
always lie in the plane
if you're folding a line
segment in the plane.
So generally, we take a
piece of paper one dimension,
we fold it in a space
that's one higher dimension,
so we're going to be
folding this thing in 2D.
We use increases that
are one lower dimension.
Here, zero dimensional points.
If we want it to be flat,
it should in the end
lie in the same dimension
the piece of paper did.
It's great because
I can just draw.
There's my piece of paper.
Here are some creases.
They're spread out however.
Maybe they're marked
mountain and valley,
and I'm not going to use
dashes and dot dashes here
because they're
points, so I'll write
m's and v's,
something like that.
And I didn't check,
but this either
will be flat foldable or not.
I think it is.
How do I know that it is?
Because we have a great
characterization that tells you
when a mountain valley
pattern is flat foldable.
Now, the first
question you might ask
is, what about
crease patterns if I
don't specify
mountains and valleys?
Then you can always
fold anything.
If I just gave you a
segment and I put creases
in some crazy pattern, all
I do is alternate mountain,
valley, mountain, valley,
mountain, valley, mountain,
valley, and I'm going to regret
making such a big example.
And I just go mountain, valley,
mountain-- it alternates.
You get some zigzag.
And this thing is not going
to collide with itself.
It just works.
In fact, you could even fold
it one step at a time left
to right by simple
folds, and you'll
get a nice flat
folding of that thing.
So every crease
pattern can be folded
with some mountain-valley
assignment, namely
the alternating accordion
pleat, but what if I give you
the mountain-valley assignment?
Sometimes I can do
it, sometimes I can't.
So here's an example where
you can't, two valleys
with some really big
segments on either side.
So when you try to fold that,
it looks something like that,
and if one of these was
really short, one of them
could tuck inside the other,
but because they're both long,
they have to collide.
That's the sort of thing
we're worried about
and we'd like to detect that
efficiently with an algorithm.
So let me tell you how.
We're going to use two
different operations,
and both of these
operations will, in fact,
be performable
using simple folds.
What we're going
to end up proving
is that a one dimensional
mountain valley
pattern is flat foldable
if and only if it's flat
foldable via a sequence
of simple folds.
So these simple folds that
we've been arguing about
are universally
powerful for 1D paper.
They are not universally
powerful for 2D paper
because you cannot fold this
pinwheel with simple folds.
There's no first fold to make.
But in one dimension,
turns out there is.
It's not obvious, but it's true.
And here, we're going to
make two very simple kinds
of simple folds.
The first one is called
an end fold, which
is you take the last, or
the very first crease,
and you just fold it over.
That's an n fold.
Now, for this to be valid
in the simple folding world,
to not get stuck,
I'm going to require
that this portion has
no creases inside it.
So it could have a crease
right at the boundary,
but there are no
creases in that region.
So when I fold this thing over,
I don't cover anything up.
No creases get covered up.
This in some sense is
clearly a good thing to do.
This may not exist.
If you find such a crease
and you make this fold,
now you can think of
this piece of paper
as sort of glued up there.
You can think of just you cut
off one part of the paper.
You made a problem even easier.
So this is clearly
a safe thing to do.
It should make your
folding easier,
but usually it doesn't exist.
In that case, we
make what's called
a crimp, which is
we have our segment.
We take two creases with
different mountain-valley
assignments.
Maybe the first one's
mountain, second one's valley,
but they're different, and
then we fold those two creases.
Something like that.
So the paper get smaller
again, but here it's
a little less clear what's
happening because there were
creases over here,
creases over here.
They got closer to each other.
Maybe that's a problem.
Maybe it messes you up.
Turns out it doesn't.
The other thing, again, we
require, if this is distance x,
we require that this region
of length x and this region
of length x is empty of creases.
There's nothing there.
You could have things
on the boundary
but nothing interior to here,
nothing interior to here,
and nothing interior to here.
Just two increases with sort
of a nice, safe neighborhood
around them so that
when I make these two
folds, this whole region,
I didn't cover anything up
in there.
There's nothing in
this Zorro mark.
That's the definition of
an n fold and a crimp.
Now, maybe these
things don't exist.
I claim if they don't exist,
you are not flat foldable
no matter what you do.
These are enough
to make everything
that is flat foldable.
We're going to prove that.
We're going to characterize
flat foldability by saying,
if I gave you some
mountain-valley pattern,
and I want to know,
is it flat foldable?
Remember, a
mountain-valley pattern
is a crease pattern together
with m's and v's written
on each crease.
I claim it is flat
foldable if and only
if there is a sequence
of crimps and end folds.
So this is saying that crimps
and end folds are all you need.
In fact, we're going to show
that you can make any crimp
and any end fold,
anything that looks valid,
anything that has these
empty regions here,
just greedily keep doing
one after the other
without regard to what's
going to happen in the future.
If you get stuck, then your
thing in the first place
was not flat foldable.
If you finish, obviously,
it was flat foldable.
You've folded it.
So it doesn't matter even what
order you do these operations.
I won't write that here,
but we will prove that.
And there's another
characterization
which we use to prove this one.
This is the one we care about.
This one's a little bit
easier to think about.
I call it the mingling property.
It says mountains and valleys
hang out with each other,
basically.
That's why I call it mingling.
So what does it mean?
If I take a whole
bunch of v's in a row,
or I take a whole bunch m's
in a row, as many as I can,
that means they're surrounded
by creases of the other type
or possibly the
edge of the paper.
But if I take a whole bunch
of v's, then the next crease
and the previous crease
are m's, let's say,
then the adjacent crease
of the other type,
or possibly the
end of the paper,
and I want this to be
true on at least one side.
This is, again, one
of those things that's
much easier in a picture, but
I will write down the words
first.
Is nearer than the adjacent
m or v. Sorry, backwards.
I'm trying to use
parallel construction here
but I got it inverted
for my notes.
Let me draw the picture.
You have a segment.
Suppose I take some maximal
sequence of m's all in a row.
So maybe on one side,
maybe the next thing
here is just the
edge of the paper
so there's no crease there.
If this was it, then I
would say this thing is not
mingling because this
distance is bigger
than this one and this distance
is bigger than this one.
So these m's are really
clustered together.
They're not mingling with
the edges, so that's bad.
And in fact, this
thing is not flat
foldable for the same
reason that one is not.
But if, for example, I put
a valley crease right here,
then this is closer than that.
I mean this distance is
smaller than that one.
So I call that mingling because
at least on the right side,
the m's are mingling
with the v's.
On the left side,
they're not mingling,
but right side's
better than nothing.
I need this to hold
on at least one side.
Could hold on both.
I claim this thing
is flat foldable.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Maybe.
It doesn't look so true.
I think I probably need some
condition on the v also.
Well, we'll see what
happens in the proof.
That's more exciting.
Usually the proof is
easier than the example.
Oh, I see why.
There's a problem here.
I think I need to say "forever."
I'll say what I
mean by that later.
The proof will still
work, but it's not
such a pretty property.
The proof is in three
parts, basically.
First part is if
you're flat foldable,
then you are mingling.
Certainly, if I want these
all to be equivalent,
it should be true that the
first one implies the third one.
This is actually
really easy to prove.
Suppose it were not mingling.
Suppose I had some
crease pattern that
violates that constraint.
What that means is I
have a bunch of m's here,
I don't know how
they're spread out.
Then I know that
there's a big gap
until the next crease,
something like that.
Well, let's think about--
there aren't really
that many ways to fold
a whole bunch of m's
in a row or a whole bunch
of v's that's symmetric.
You pretty much have
to spiral around.
You're always turning
the same direction.
If it's flat foldable, which
is what we're assuming here,
it's got to look
kind of like that.
In fact, it has two ends,
so it could actually
make two spirals.
But if you think about
what happens there,
this last part at the end of the
spirals, that's this segment.
That's when you possibly turn
around the other direction.
Maybe this is the valley.
But take a look at
what's going on here.
This segment is tucked
inside the spiral.
If it's super long
like it is here,
if it's longer than the previous
portion-- let me label this.
This is x, this is x,
this is y, this is y.
That looks really bad.
x has to be smaller than y.
Otherwise, it's going
to penetrate right
through that corner.
In this case with the double
spiral, double spiral all
the way, what does it mean?
I guess no one knows
double rainbow.
Bad stuff.
In the double spiral
case, in fact, this end
must be shorter than
this one and this one
must be shorter than this one.
So in this case, you must
be mingling on both sides,
but it doesn't have
to be that way.
If it's just a single
spiral, this last segment
can be really long.
That's OK.
It's much longer than this
one, but the inner part
of the spiral must
always be smaller
than the next segment
of the spiral,
and that's exactly
what mingling says.
Could be on the left, could be
on the right, you don't know.
But on at least one of the
sides, you must be mingling.
And therefore, if you're going
to have a flat folding at all,
you must be mingling.
Clear?
Question?
AUDIENCE: When you say a maximal
sequence, what do you mean?
PROFESSOR: Maximal
means that you
can't make it any
bigger locally.
I can't add any more
creases and still
have a contiguous
bunch of mountains.
It's a good question.
In mathematics, there's
maximal and maximum.
Maximal means locally biggest,
maximum means globally biggest.
So I don't mean take
the biggest sequence
of contiguous m's you can find.
I just mean take some contiguous
sequence of m's that you
can't make any bigger
on either side.
I just mean that it's
surrounded by valleys.
I want this to hold for every
contiguous sequence of m's.
That's one of those funny
math technical terms.
Other questions?
So that's the first thing.
Somehow I want to connect all
these properties together.
The next part is that
if you're mingling,
either there's an end
fold or there's a crimp.
At least one of those two
things must be possible.
So this would be good
news because if I'm
flat foldable,
then I'm mingling.
If I'm mingling, then
there's a fold I can make.
That seems like progress.
Then I have to show that
I don't mess anything up
when I make that fold.
But if I could keep going
in a circle like this,
then I would keep being
able to make folds,
and then eventually I
would fold the whole thing
because there's only
end folds at the end.
I'll have made them all.
It's not that much
trickier, I guess.
It involves parentheses.
That's one way to write it.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So right
now, the main property
is finding a way that
[INAUDIBLE] two or more?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: And there is an
example that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just ignore this.
It'll be easier to
think of it that way.
I'm going to use mingling
to prove this property,
but this is not equivalent
to those properties.
You need to add
"forever," but that's
too confusing at the moment.
This is a definition
of mingling.
We're going to use it
as a separate thing,
and I'm going to prove these
two things are equivalent.
Then I'll be correct.
Correct is always a good thing.
So what I want to do is for each
of these mingling sequences,
for each maximal
sequence of m's or v's, I
want to write down two symbols.
I'm going to write a curved
left parenthesis if it
is left mingling, meaning I have
all these mountains, let's say.
Draw it in a reasonable way.
Then I'm happy on the left side.
I'm mingling with a v with
an m fold on the left side.
I know it's either left
mingling or it's right mingling.
I'm assuming mingling here.
I will write a square
bracket if it's not.
Then I will write a
curved right bracket
if you're right
mingling, which is just
the same picture but
on the other side.
And I'm going to write a closed
square bracket if it's not.
Then I claim that
parentheses sequence
has some nice properties.
So for example, this
is a string that I get.
It might look like
this, maybe that.
Who knows?
It looks like something.
I know that every pair, at least
one of the two sides is curved.
I can't have them both be
square because then you're
not mingling at all.
I know I'm always mingling
left or mingling right,
so it's something.
Now, one thing
that's really good
is I have no double
square bracket.
That's impossible.
I also know that
if I had something
like this, what does that mean?
It means I have a bunch
of mountains over here,
then I have a very
nearby valley, and then
a bunch of valleys
over here, and I
know that the mountains
are right mingling, which
means I know that
x is bigger than y.
That's what this symbol means.
It means to the right of the
m's, I've got a small gap,
and it means to the left of the
v's, I also have a small gap.
That means y is also bigger
than this z distance.
AUDIENCE: Smaller.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Smaller.
I'm too tempted to
combine them together,
but it's a funny looking thing.
y is smaller than both x and z.
So then what do I do?
Crimp.
That was sort of the
definition of a crimp,
that at least if I took
this region x and copied it
over here, those were
empty of creases.
And now we're saying that
there's a big gap here.
I guess technically
it's bigger than
or equal to if you said
all these things right.
I said "nearer," but I
meant non-strictly nearer.
It's enough to do a crimp.
So if I find this, I'm happy.
The other thing that
I'm really happy with
is if I have an open
paren at the beginning,
a curved parenthesis,
open parenthesis,
at the beginning of the
string, or a right parenthesis
at the end of the
string, because that
means I can do an end fold.
That means that you have
a very short segment
at the very beginning so
you can just fold it over.
This means you have a
short segment at the end.
Just fold it over.
So as long as I can find
one of these three things,
I am golden.
I have what I want, which
was an end fold or a crimp.
How do I prove that I
have one of those things?
The easy way is
by contradiction.
Just imagine if you didn't
have any one of these things,
it's pretty forced what you
have to have in your string
because you know you must start
with an open square bracket.
You also know that you cannot
then immediately have a closed
square bracket, so you
must have a closed paren.
Now I know that I cannot have
an open paren because then
I'd have this, and that
would be good for me.
So if I want to be bad, I have
to have an open square bracket,
but then I'd have to
have a closed paren,
and then I'd have to have an
open square bracket, and so on.
In the end, you will have
a closed paren at the end,
and that means you
can make an end fold.
So either something
failed in here.
Maybe I had two parens
together-- then I
would have gotten
a crimp-- or I can
keep going all the
way through here
and get a closed
paren at the end.
In any case, I get at least
one of these three things
happening, and so I get
either an end fold or a crimp
assuming I am mingling.
And instead of
assuming I am mingling,
I can just assume that
I'm flat foldable,
and then I get from this
chain of implications
that there is an
end fold or a crimp.
OK so far?
So that means I can
make at least one fold.
If I am flat foldable, I can
make at least one crimp or end
fold.
Now the question is,
can I keep going?
For that, we need
one more property.
If I make a crimp
or an end fold,
I want to prove that that
preserves flat foldability.
What that means is if I
start with something that's
flat foldable and then I
make a crimp or an end fold,
I will still be flat foldable.
This is the property
I need because it
will let me close the chain.
I'm flat foldable,
therefore I'm mingling,
therefore I have an end fold
or a crimp, so I make it.
This property says that I
will still be flat foldable,
therefore number
one applies again.
I'm still mingling, I
can still find a fold,
and I'm still flat foldable,
so I'm still mingling.
I can still find a fold.
I can keep going.
I will never get
stuck because I'm
guaranteed if I
started flat foldable,
I will be flat foldable forever.
I will also be mingling forever.
I realize now but
apparently have not
realized before, it's not
enough to be mingling just
at the beginning.
You have to be mingling
through every step there.
In fact, what we're
showing is that you're
fat foldable at every step,
which implies mingling,
but mingling is
not quite enough.
You'd have to check it
all the way through.
That's why I stated
the theorem wrong.
How do we prove this
theorem, this claim?
I'm going to do it
proof by picture.
It's not always OK,
but it will be OK.
Trust me.
We are assuming that
we're flat foldable
and we're assuming there's
a crimp or an end fold.
Actually, we know
that that exists.
I'm going to think
about the crimp case
because end fold
is even simpler.
See, here's the thing.
I would really like to fold
some crimp like this, let's say.
This is an m, this
is a v. What I'm
claiming is I'm allowed
to make that crimp first
and then do everything else,
but conceivably, there's
some flat folding that
doesn't make this crimp first.
I mean, it must
fold this mountain
and it must fold this
valley, but at some point.
We don't really know when.
Somehow it all
simultaneously collapses
into some flat folding.
Now, this thing should be flat.
It should line in a line.
I'm stretching it out
so you can see it.
It's a segment
that we're folding,
so maybe it does this,
some crazy thing.
Maybe this part does
something crazy here,
goes there, whatever.
We know it's not crossing
and it's sort of horizontal,
but it could be an ugly mess.
And in particular,
in this picture,
it does not look like this crimp
was done first-- maybe embolden
the crimp here-- because there's
this stuff in the middle.
Now, we know that there's
no creases in here.
We know the earliest we can turn
is at the ends of the crimp.
But there could be stuff that
comes in the middle here.
What do I do?
I just move the
stuff out of the way.
Let me do this the right way.
Got to do this a
little bit carefully,
and unfortunately, my
picture is so messy,
hopefully you can see it.
So I'm going to take this part,
which is inside the crimp,
I'm going to move
it down here, just
lower those layers down to here.
Now I know locally,
there's a fold right here.
And so if I take all
the stuff that's in here
and move it down here, it
will still be non-crossing.
And then I take this stuff
and I move it up here.
Equivalently, you can
think of me crushing this
down and crushing this
up, but it's actually
important the direction
these things go.
I could not put this stuff up
here because I don't really
know how long this goes.
It's not valid for me
to try to put it up.
I could collide with something.
But I know that there's
a crease right here,
so I can put it right over here.
I can take this stuff and
put it right over here.
This is a weird kind of
manipulation of folded states
which we don't normally do,
but here we need to do it.
After I've done that--
is there any hope
of me redrawing the picture?
Maybe.
After we've done that,
we'll have the crimp.
It will be nice and tight.
And then we'll have
this finger here,
and then it goes up
here, up this anvil.
Then this part, instead
of going inside,
actually goes in here, up
there, something like that,
and that's the end.
Then this is the other side.
Other side wasn't too
complicated, I think.
But you can check.
I guess now it's down here.
But you can really just
do the shifting locally
and it doesn't mess anything up.
I'm going to wave my
hands because it's
a bit messy to
really prove that.
But if you do that, boom.
Now this crimp looks like
it was actually done first.
You can see that this
folded state could
have been made by first doing
that crimp and then folding
the rest.
You can treat this as if the
paper was fused together here,
and that will be a folded state
of that smaller piece of paper.
So even though we were shifting
creases closer to each other
and it looked a little
scary what's happening,
we know from this
construction if you
could fold the original thing,
you can fold the thing even
when the crimp got
fused together.
Therefore, crimps
are always safe,
and by an even easier argument,
end folds are always safe.
I already gave that
argument, basically.
So a little crazy,
but that proves
that you preserve
flat foldability
by going in this chain
n or n over 2 times,
you will fold everything if you
were originally flat foldable.
If you're not, you will get
stuck because otherwise, you
would find a folding, and so on.
Clear?
I'll just mention
you can generalize
this to folding two dimensional
maps with simple folds.
I should say, of course, an
end fold is a simple fold.
A crimp is two simple folds.
You can first fold
along the mountain,
you won't get any collision, and
then fold back on the valley.
That's a simple fold.
So this is saying,
in fact, something
is flat foldable
in one dimension if
and only if it is flat foldable
by a sequence of simple folds.
As long as you stick to
crimps and end folds,
it doesn't matter what
order you do them in.
That's not true as soon as
you go to two dimensions.
So for example, just
for fun, do I really
want to draw the whole thing?
I guess I've committed.
There's a couple
examples in the notes
that you can take a look at,
and I encourage you to make one.
This can be folded flat
but not by simple folds,
and you can see that it can't
be followed by simple folds
because there's no fold that
goes all the way through.
This line is valley,
mountain, mountain.
There's no line that's all
mountains or all valleys.
But you can use this structure
to understand at least which
rectangular maps with
horizontal and vertical creases
can be folded flat
by simple folds,
and the answer would be no here.
All you do is you say, well,
I know if there's any fold,
I must have a mountain
or a valley that
goes all the way through.
So Imagine here's
your rectangle.
There's got to be something
that's valley all the way.
Now, if you think about a crease
that goes the other direction,
these are two valleys.
You can show, just by playing
around with a little pattern
like this, you cannot have
these two both be valleys
because that would be
all four valleys is bad.
If you try that, doesn't work.
Or it also can't
be both mountains.
You can't valley, mountain,
valley, mountain in order.
That doesn't fold.
So in fact, these
have to be different.
One's mountain, one's valley.
I don't care which is which, but
I know that this line actually
cannot be folded
by a simple fold.
It's got a valley
and a mountain.
So in fact, the picture has
to be I have a line like this.
Maybe I have a few lines that
are mountains all the way
or valleys all the way.
And any horizontal
line I can't fold.
I've got to finish
folding these guys first.
That means I have a one
dimensional problem.
So I apply this algorithm
to see whether that one
dimensional thing folds.
Once I've folded all
those vertical things,
solved that one
dimensional problem,
I will then have a
horizontal problem,
and then I'll have
a vertical problem.
You just keep
doing this, and you
can show in the
same way you always
preserve flat foldability.
You just keep doing
crimps and end folds,
and this will fold
your map if it's
at all possible by simple
folds, which most ones that
are in production are
foldable by simple folds.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If we go back to the
example where [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
mountain, it would be reversed
and then it would be
foldable [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is good.
This is the case
that could work.
This is foldable
if you try it out.
You first told here,
and then the valley
falls onto the mountain but it
turns upside down as it folds,
and so they actually nest
nicely inside each other.
It's confusing because
it's inverting.
This is the one valley
case, but my point
is you have to fold this
before you fold that.
There's a little more
details in the notes here.
You can make this into a really
fast linear time algorithm
if you use fancy
data structures,
but that's beyond
this scope, and that
is the end of lecture two.